[Music]
terror attack has declared a state of
emergency as you can see London's having
a rough time api-- what with these nasty
opportunists seizing control that's
where you come in welcome to the
resistance it's up to you to build the
perfect team and take the city back the
good news is that ami Londoner could
become your next recruit you can play as
anyone and they've all got their own
gameplay skills see this charming
chappie let's Victor what he only takes
off the amount of damage after his neck
to point or for chop man
and her that suit top-notch lawyer once
in your team she can get your operatives
out of jail automatically you don't even
need to lift a finger
nice one sue and this is ellen old
codger and veritable mad bastard
increased damage with rifles and wait
hold may die randomly or IP Ellen
moving on everyone is different so you
have to decide what's best for your team
but why would these fine people want to
join you well everyone's got an origin
story I want you to help me get revenge
on the gang stop help them with their
problem and once they trust you they
will become playable characters each one
of your new best friends is a unique
gameplay build so dust off your sorting
hat and give them a class then level
them up and unlock new perks
there are thousands of possibilities
whether you've got a net for gizmos
[Music]
all you'd rather stalk people from the
shadows
building a team with diverse skills will
be critical to your success each new
recruit will make your team stronger you
can even customize your team members
their lovely heads of course accidents
can happen don't worry if you're small
you could always surrender no shame in
that
anyone got Sue's number luckily our city
is filled with millions of people and
any single one of them could be your
next recruit
[Music]
who's calling get out there and take it
[Music]